babe look at these hearts okay this is
my mood at you all always Miley Cyrus is
praising her new boo while seeming to
slam her ex
during an Instagram live with Cody
Simpson on Sunday the 26 year old singer
told her fans not to lose hope when it
comes to love they're good men out there
guys don't give up you don't have to be
gay there are good people with dict out
there you just got to find out you got
to find it picking on me oh snap
but she did not stop there Miley bashed
some of the other men she's met over the
years leading some fans to think she was
throwing some not so subtle shade at her
ex Liam Hemsworth whom she split from
back in August I always thought I had to
be Giggs I just thought like all the
guys were evil but it's not true
there are good people out there that
just happen to have to hang on this life
awkward we ship every stand each other
is so hard I have no choice
I have no choice but stand you know
we're literally past couple laughter of
all time
Miley and Cody were first linked earlier
this month following her breakups with
both Liam and Caitlin Carter since then
the two have been all about that PDA
Cody even released a song about Miley
called golden thing
[Music]
in the first day
and the chorus
dawnie yeah so those lyrics have some
believing he's already said I love you
[Music]
the 26 year old first revealed Cody
penned a song about her on her instace
story at the time Miley was hospitalized
for tonsillitis and Cody showed up with
his guitar to cheer her up
I mean saloon
Miley shared this snap of her man
writing this sweet guy came to visit me
at the hospital and saying the sweetest
song he wrote just for me it's too
special to be only heard in full by my
ears so I am currently pressuring him to
drop it next week and it's working
hashtag golden thing oh and let's not
forget my Lee called Cody her bf on
instagram the two got tattoos together
and posed for this sexy AF shot she's
definitely like a very like that hot a
very very sweet normal like gopher from
Nashville like and we were spending
hanging out at her ranch in Nashville
and she's just like I'm just like a lot
of people say these things like that you
know she's just like the coolest Jake
yeah things seem to be pretty hot and
heavy between Cody and Miley but at the
beginning of their romance a source told
et that they have quote no plans to
start dating each other exclusively
Miley and Cody have been friends for
years they have hooked up in the past
they both just want to have fun and are
open and honest with each other about
that the source added quote Miley and
Cody talked to each other about
everything they are very close and feel
comfortable sharing details with each
other about their lives meanwhile Liam
appears to have moved on to he was
recently spotted cozying up with dynasty
star Madison Brown in New York guys I'm
not gonna lie to you I didn't get Miley
and Cody at first but now I'm fully
onboard they couldn't be cuter and you
can count on us to bring you all the
detail
of their budding love so make sure to
keep it locked right here on et until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]